holy [ __ ] we're at year's end we made it
2016 is coming to an end folks at some
points it felt like 2016 had some teeth
and at the end of every year I picked my
top ten favorite movies of that year and
do a video for you guys hence this is my
top 10 favorite movies of 2016 couple
things to note one these are not reviews
of the movies I have my reviews I'll
actually have annotations over here over
the posters for those of you who want to
be like Laura see more about what he
said about that click you can do that
and two these are just my personal
opinions these are not that technically
perfect movies of 2016 for those of you
who have come here for validation on
your top 10 favorite films of 2016 or
you've come to hear me gush about the
Oscar Paint movies of 2016 you're going
to be very disappointed it's just my
personal list of the movies I thought
were pretty swell that's not to say
there were only 10 great films this year
when I was making my list of a
surprisingly large amount of movies that
oh like hey I really like that but I
have to whittle it down to 10 so now I
got 10 and important to know this year
as every year I haven't seen all the
movies that have come out in 2016 the
movie I really wanted to catch before I
did this list which I wouldn't catch his
silence Martin Scorsese's new movie I
don't know if it would make this list
there people out there who are like
we'll just wait until you watch all the
movies that is impossible or I did my
top 10 best list 2012 at that point
you're telling me wait five years before
I do this list for this year not gonna
happen
might as well just get this going and as
these top 10 list can drag on I don't
want to drag it on so let's get right
into it these are my top 10 favorite
movies of 2016
no but hey starting off this list is
Moana I figured I'd like Moana I didn't
know I'd loved Moana I didn't know I'd
loved Moana as much as I loved Moana but
Moana totally worked for me it was a
cool adventure I love the rock I love
the music I love the voice acting I love
the way they executed it we want to work
it was a great adventure for kids and
adults coming in at number 9 we have the
edge of seventeen this was a surprise if
ever there was one there are a few
surprises on this list age of 17 I
didn't know you could make a John Hughes
esque movie in 2016 if John Hughes was
still alive still making movies in 2016
I'm very sure this is what he would make
it was a sweet movie it had heart it had
guts and a really cool teacher had a
couple teachers like Woody Harrelson in
this film they're out there I
of them this movie gave me the fields it
was a great time took you right back to
your high school years for better for
worse no but eat next up we have the
next animation which was in direct
competition from Alana for my heart
that's Kubo in the two strings boo-boo
in the two strings was the Legend of
Zelda movie we haven't gotten nor will
we probably ever get it was beautiful in
its style aesthetic execution I love the
characters I love the craft I love the
Lord did I say it was Legend of Zelda
yet yeah I'm gonna say it again cuz it
totally was really good looking one at
that number seven next we have Patriots
Day funny thing about Patriots Day
Patriots day was the last movie I
watched and reviewed before I started
doing this list so given time to
marinate I don't know if it would get
higher on the list it might who knows
all I know is Patriots Day solidified
the fact that Peter Berg has found
himself something he's found a path
stick to that path he could be great it
was raw in its execution yes but it also
hit to the point the fact that people do
come together in a time of crisis and
that's a beautiful thing about humanity
and that's something this movie does
celebrate this movie hit me where I live
and it really does show that you don't
have to wait decades before doing a
movie about a tragic event
it helps hit the point home and this
movie does hit its point home number six
she knew it would be on this list
because I'm just I'm a fan of it rogue
one a Star Wars story or Star Wars rogue
one for people who want to call it that
it does sound better now I enjoyed rogue
one when I saw it that's no secret but
given time to marinate I didn't expect
rogue one to do what it did and that is
sew up the loose ends and give gravity
to the events of the original Star Wars
movie Star Wars a new hope if you watch
rogue one and then go right into a new
hope when that death star blows up you
really feel like it's two movies worth
of events leading up to that and as a
companion piece alone it wouldn't make
my list but the fact that the movie
itself was actually entertaining and had
great moments and one of my favorite
Star Wars mug you know seeing I'm
talking about rogue one just had to make
the list so it did 5 next up we have the
Valentine's Day movie of Valentine's Day
movies as right that's Deadpool after
this movie took ten years to any movie
that takes this long to make it's not
usually a good sign
in fact the move you might actually suck
but when we saw the campaign leading up
to it we were like wait that's
that's a really good meta campaign
they're doing maybe they found Deadpool
maybe they're doing it right holy [ __ ]
they totally did it right and I'm
telling Deadpool has changed the game no
longer do studios feel they have to
steer away from the r-rated comic book
movies we've had them before but they
didn't do what Deadpool did really
Deadpool is a testament to just stick to
the source material stick to the
character do both of them justice it
doesn't matter what the rating is the
fans will respond and also the movie was
[ __ ] awesome next up we have Peter
Berg's other film that came out in 2016
deepwater horizon kind of felt weird
putting two Peter Burton movies on here
the dude directed to film on my top 10
list yeah I overlooked my list a hundred
times this film deserves to be on here
and the fact that Deepwater Horizon and
pay trees day are so different in
execution I'm fine with it but Deepwater
Horizon does it shows you the scope and
magnitude of the event that happened in
that oils it wasn't just an oil spill
wasn't just a fire this is one of the
best disaster movies I have seen on the
big screen it executed it well it
sounded great it looked great I was in
awe of it and then you stop you realize
holy [ __ ] that really happened then you
get more interested you start googling
things because you're like folks need to
be accountable for that [ __ ] was a
relevant piece of film in 2016 I really
believe that love this one we all right
right the top three now and generally I
like to thank my top ten films do
kick-ass they do in my mind's eye anyway
but the top three men these are the ones
that really hit me and starting at the
top three at number three that is Mel
Gibson's return hacksaw ridge hacksaw
Ridge showed me that a Mel Gibson is a
great director I haven't seen this dude
do anything for a decade maybe he's
burned out maybe he's washed up maybe
he's faded into obscurity because of the
[ __ ] he said controversy aside the dude
knows how to direct this is a very
heartfelt movie for the first half of it
of someone just standing his ground
going no I'm not picking up a gun
because I don't believe in it then he
gets to the battlefield and it turns
into a holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
slaughterhouse and this dude is going to
save people's lives it really is a
testament to the human spirit great
performance from Andrew Garfield great
directing from Mel Gibson I genuinely
look forward to seeing what Mel Gibson
does next
but true well you haven't seen it on my
list yet and here it is the one you knew
would be on my list Captain America
Civil War Captain America Civil War was
not only a great Throwdown among the
super heroes it was building up we knew
it would happen that airport Throwdown
is arguably the greatest superhero
Throwdown I've ever seen on the big
screen no I'm not arguably it just is
faking awesome superhero greatness and
action yeah that's great to see
but like Captain America Winter Soldier
before it Civil War was also a great
movie of conflict among the characters
we have grown to love that's the thing
that Marvel has built it's what they've
done is what they're executing really
well now the characters are established
we've known them since 2009 when Iron
Man 1 came out and now there is
logically conflict among the ranks of
the Avengers it all came to a head in
this one pick a side I don't want to
pick a side feel like I have to pick a
side oh my god and like I said in my
review if you do not flip-flop from team
cap to team Iron Man back and forth vice
versa at least once in this film you're
just blindly following because this film
does make compelling arguments for both
sides and that's tough to do but it's
important to do and Civil War did it
no oh what's it gonna be folks what's it
gonna be my number one Star Wars is
already on here Captain America Civil
War is already on here you guys have no
idea right now do you and I'm gonna let
you know it's arrival arrival made me
nervous going into it because people
were like illegal arrivals so amazing
and usually when I have critics and
people telling me arrival is so amazing
I have to go see it it usually means I'm
gonna watch it I'm going to like it I'm
not gonna like it as much as the
internet tells me I should like it and
then the internet gets all pissed in the
comment sections about it as poignant as
I was nervous going into this and I
walked out loving it this was a great
movies it's a movie about how language
is so important to our development and
how we interact not only culturally but
as a species as a whole there are layers
to this movie and to that point that I'm
not going to ruin for you on the off
chance you haven't seen arrival you
should see arrival I feel like amy adams
should be nominated for an oscar this
movie itself should be I might be a
little biased it being my number 1 this
is not an alien invasion movie know that
right now this is a thinking persons
movie you go in there you sit down you
get information and the human race is
put under a social microscope sounds
really cliche but in this execute
it's not a great movie and an important
movie and it's a movie you should
certainly say it is my number one my
favorite film of 2016 alright guys so
that's my list those are the 10 movies
this year that made me go yeah they need
to be on the most important list on the
Internet
not at all but you know and I know my
list is different than your list your
list is different than my list our lists
are not the same nor should they be
that's the great thing about cinema it's
a great thing about film so your top 10
favourite films of 2016 what are they
whatever they are comment below let me
know make that list down below let's
start that conversation but let's keep
it civil and yes the top 10 worst of
2016 per my opinion that videos coming
next oh yeah there were some and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]